i have a burning question
jordan allen when you are doing a
british accent do you have to fake a
british accent it's 100 fake i feel i
feel gross doing it
i feel like a phony it's funny i went to
uh england on a trip over one summer and
when i came back to high school i made
the conscious decision to pretend
hoping that eventually it would set
and within a day i felt like a scumbag
yeah i bailed i bailed i don't even do a
good one how long were you over there
like was it like oh i was there for two
days solid three weeks yeah i mean it's
a little weird
come back
what's wrong with you what are you
trying to impress here so do your
parents have an accident or no they do
yeah okay mom and dad both have an
accident so you feel like you don't have
a solid enough foundation to like kind
of get away with faking it
what kind of life is that you know what
i mean well i mean like i can't let
anyone just learn so far and distinguish
one yeah
it would serve me in many ways it really
would it'd be very beneficial to have a
british accent i'm aware of this yeah
many people have told me this you know
when it comes to like statistics like
you know being white and being male 1
let's say at the top of the game having
a british accent is even the tip top of
that yeah that's you've climbed to the
top of the cake and then there's a
you've ascended the cherry yeah with the
british accent yeah
yeah and so i've held on to some of the
vernacular i certainly used some words
that are british like um well now i'm
i'm on the spot
i feel like i've heard it well the other
day i i was out with uh with my
girlfriend and some friends and i i said
oh that was lovely but it was sincere
like sincerely that was a lovely meal
and i guess lovely isn't
used very often yeah it's a little more
i don't know flowery over here i feel
like in in britain it's very common
parliament oh that's lovely
so yeah i wish i had it did we talk
about this the other day do you say zed
or z i say z
where does zed come from uh the moon
canada i don't know
alien species yeah i say zed though like
zed depth pass
oh you say zed yeah that's very canadian
because well actually i thought about
this recently because i was like well
most letters they sound
like it's the sound you make
you associate it with that letter yeah
but except for w
yeah because you don't say w
z
i no longer respect z is better and it
rhymes if you're saying about the
alphabet it rhymes yeah there you go
a little language well nico right before
this you were trying to tie your shoe
with one hand yeah because i wonder if
you can explain to the audience why you
don't have use of your left arm yeah
well so for
i got to ask this question a lot because
we were in vegas over the weekend at nab
which stands for north american
association of broadcasters it's
basically the big convention where all
the software and cameras and stuff gets
shown off it's like it's a convention we
can go to where we have colleagues that
aren't like influencers right like we
have our like youtuber influencery
colleagues and we have our like video
production filmmaker colleagues and like
nab is like the the filmmaker side of it
um but i got asked this question a
million times what happened to your arm
and thankfully i broke my collarbone
doing something cool because if i broke
my collarbone doing something lame it
would be a tough time
but yeah last weekend um i went over the
handles handlebars my mountain bike
slipped on some dirt on the i was going
downhill
on this little swoopy park so i didn't
want to lift my bike over the gate so i
decided to do the really tricky steep
washed-out dirt thing like a little
water gullet i'm like i'll just i'll
just i'll just manage the side of this
little gully here
and my bike kind of slipped a little
weird and i tried to get back in it's
really steep hit my brakes a little bit
the front tire twists around and i have
nowhere to go but over my handlebars i
try to roll it out just turns out to be
a pile drive into the ground into my
shoulder and you just you just tell
instantly like the amount of force that
just went into my shoulder is more than
the structural integrity of my shoulder
like something had to have something's
got to give yeah you know uh
let the bodies at the floor so
as they say as they say
thankfully it was really at the very end
of the trail so i got up walked 20 feet
down to the road and laid down uh ghee
was with me um so he's he's had some
practice with taking big injuries and
having to deal with that
and uh
my wife wouldn't answer the phone i
called him like oh so i called peter
i think you wanted her to pick me up
peter i broke my
phone i didn't actually know i broke my
collarbone like i just like i fell off
my bike fairly badly that's amazing so
he came out and helped out and uh yeah
beautiful i love that you fell to your
training too when you went over it went
through your head to do a stunt roll
yeah like that that is pretty cool i
wouldn't have thought of that like yeah
that's that's pretty i mean it didn't
work it worked in the past i did i did i
was driving an atv and a root hooked
across the front axle and threw me over
the front of the atv and i emerged from
that unscathed feeling really cool
because i did like a full flip and
everything's like huh
and that didn't work out this time is
this your worst like injury you've had
like i've never broken a bone before wow
oh yeah that's my first time breaking a
bone no way damn yeah so 10 10 would
recommend you into that club you haven't
broken a bone i i have
many i mean honestly like here's the
thing like
it's going to get me less sympathy but
it really isn't that bad
through the pillow
you're done like it's not even in the
same realm as wren's i'm not any on any
painkillers right now yeah
what was the difference oh you chipped
the end of it well i didn't chip it the
end snapped it's like it's imagine the
head of a match breaking that match it
off and then breaking that that's worse
than a chip yeah so that's what happened
but ren's broke right in the middle of
his collarbone and it like exploded yeah
there's like splints and everything oh
man yeah i think my mind's all aligned
it's all set up there's a picture on my
instagram if you want to go take a look
check it out but yeah it's uh the main
thing is i'm just like
i feel like i was really good about
not messing it up the moment it happened
like i crashed broke it and it's like
something's wrong i kept my shoulder
like stabilized
and i think they just kept the pieces
aligned you know there's a lot of flesh
in there it's kind of holding things in
place
hopefully
i don't know how it actually works but
i'm just guessing
yeah but i got some x-rays it's like
it's broken it's like all right the
thing is i went to urgent care uh the
day of and the person before me in
urgent care was having an allergic
reaction to something that was closing
her airway
so i went in after her and the doctor is
just
so elevated and yeah so hyped up they're
like what happened i'm like i i fell off
my bike they're like yeah you should go
to the ehr right now like well i mean i
landed on my shoulders like you could be
bleeding internally you could die right
here on like he's just in full hero
i'm like
i'm like i respect that
i don't think i am but i respect it but
i do i think i'm okay it's like we need
to get you like a neck brace like i
don't think my neck's broken i can i'm
really like doing this like i think i'm
okay
i think i just you know broke something
in my shoulder or whatever can we get an
x-ray please
don't want to go do a cat scan right now
it's 9 p.m like just an x-ray uh sure
you know i got the x-ray but they made
me put like my arm up which is a little
like funky yeah he didn't want to peek
too early that night so he was trying he
was really trying to escalate
get the tv my heart's beating i respect
it my heart's beating like i know you're
the professional
but i think my heart's still beating
[Laughter]
yeah man so yeah living life uh with one
arm and it's it's
inconvenient and slow but still managed
to finish your bowling animation still
managed to finish my bowling animation
which is
i actually wanted to talk to you guys
about how do you be
uh how do you be offensive and not be
offensive like how can you be all right
so if you're listening to this you
probably saw our slightly offensive
bowling animations and uh video that we
did we did a second one it should be
coming out
in a week or so yeah i think something
no this is before this is coming up
no it's already out it's all right it's
coming sorry everybody
um so
how do you guys
like i actually find offensive humor
like really funny which is like not a
thing i broadcast at all but like
yeah um how do you guys make something
offensive and funny where it's not
actually offensive like what's the trick
i don't know man my only ideas were
either like very lightly offensive or
like i was gonna get canceled and i was
like i i don't i don't want to come in
hot like jordan
yeah yeah i don't do not recommend we
were joking about it but do you feel
like there's actually a different scale
for it in canada like is that just like
it's the whole perspective perspective
of like i know canadians are nice like i
actually do yeah i think
i would think i think people are more
easily offended in canada maybe yeah i
think like how dare you say that yeah
i'm sorry i'm sorry
because i feel like you and then england
i feel like would have would be able to
stand even more than the us or do you
think that perception's wrong it depends
where you are in england yeah doesn't it
yeah there's the there's the posh
sectors and then there's the uh the
northerners
have fun the scousers it's a pretty dark
british humor yeah yeah no i i certainly
have a northern sense of humor i i love
like offensive stuff or stuff that makes
me gasp yeah and then i will follow it
with a laugh which i can't believe
someone would make that yeah
yeah let's watch it again um and yeah i
think the the balance is interesting
because that was something i was
thinking about this in the second
iteration since i missed the mark on the
first one
you know what let me let me reassess and
it almost feels like it it's all fine as
long as it's in service of a rewarding
punchline
you know and i i certainly dialed back
the offensive on on my
on my animation this time certainly in
the context of everybody else's i was
shocked
yeah i was shocked i thought there was
going to be hard on this one
i thought given the response of the last
one
uh that that there was going to be a
dial back but it was such a ramp up and
then i was immediately sitting there
thinking i should have done more i
should have gone i should have gone
worse because like any any project it's
like if you do it again you have to push
it and
the problem here is that pushing it is
like in offensiveness yeah so that you
can't really like
it's hard because we were already really
towing that line last time and then this
time everybody's like i guess we go a
little harder and then it's like
holocaust
yeah there's like two holocaust jokes
yeah
it's it's a it's an interesting
balancing act you know but yeah i i
don't know i'm always i'm of the mindset
that everything should be joked about
yeah you know what i mean it is a coping
mechanism like yeah at the end of the
day it's the way that humans way for us
to deal with pain
yeah yeah it's true i think like
the key
is
making it so
ridiculous that it's totally clear that
you don't
believe
like i think the point of picking
something extremely offensive
is that like clearly nobody
is
like oh the holocaust was stupid you
know
so
or you know whatever it is you know it's
just like
you have to
be able to pick a subject where it's
clear that
you know i'm just being i'm i'm doing
this just for the sake of like
bowling pins are funny in this context
because you know why why else would you
do this well that yeah that's the thing
is like in an offensive animation to me
what is funniest is making the person
bowling feel as guilty as possible for
enjoying just a very innocent pastime
and making them not want to continue
which is the antithesis of what these
things should be they should like
celebrate you and make you want to get
back up there and try again and
the other side of that is where the
humor is to me and uh yeah i think for
me though it's it's
being aware that you know the
i guess the the application of that idea
and your intention for doing it your
intention can certainly be removed when
someone sees it out of context and being
aware that hey they can associate you to
this work without giving the context the
proper appreciation which is what makes
it funny in the first place and instead
makes it wow you think that's okay
literally any walk of life you can just
say you think that's okay to me that's
not okay yeah and that there's everyone
has a different and certainly
they're i'm sure in the comments we
haven't seen them yet but there will be
people who are yeah there will be people
who's like i mean there were the last
one yeah which is one of those things
was like look i get it but it's like
it's really hard
like it's hard to take someone seriously
when they get offended at one of our
pulling animations like i know i know
it's offensive that's why we yeah that's
the point
like we can all do it like the context
yeah like we're going into this context
like okay everybody watching we're doing
this to specifically to be offensive we
don't actually support any of these
things yeah we're not we're not
making light of it and i think when you
call it out to be like this is
specifically offensive it like takes the
power out of it too because you're like
man we're joking about this like it's
clearly we're not doing this in a
malicious way yeah you know like ren had
the point of view which i thought was
interesting it was like you have to go
one step further beyond just taking a
tragedy and putting bowling pins and
bowling balls in that tragedy yeah it's
like
that can be funny but you're really just
getting shock humor it's like when you
can add one more joke to it somehow then
it's like okay now we're getting there
yeah a threshold of creativity
besides yeah replacing the the twin
towers with pins and yeah a bowling ball
playing and i i felt like yours
did that very well because thank you you
know we kind of all get got it the
subject matter but when the spared thing
is like it's that's the joke is
a pun it's like the pun at the end of
this super like yeah and yeah what made
me laugh about some of these is that
they're they were so open-ended like we
we know what the intention was to
display yeah but really if you're
getting upset about it you filled in the
blanks
like nothing offensive happened in yours
but it's like the content like if you
like you're like oh god
what happens the next day is offensive
yeah i was worried that actually like
people didn't find my [ __ ] mind funny
because there was no laughing
until the final spared title hit the
screen oh it was funny because i think
it was just quiet it's all built up
everybody's waiting like oh no that's
gonna happen and then it's like it's
almost actually kind of like a happy
ending
you're one of them yeah yeah
it was so nice of that bowling pins
friend to tell him not to come to school
tomorrow to remind him it was a national
holiday
i had actually assumed that there was a
pop quiz that he found out about oh she
was like that's where my mind was
getting you're sick and stay home
because you need to study more exactly
right yeah yeah yeah that's where my
mind went
so
i
i don't know if this came across or came
through but my intention with the one
step pushing it further
was like i don't know if you guys
remember like there's a like the baby
starts crying and that's what alerts the
guy upstairs that they're down there and
just having this like like
you already know upfront it's like okay
this is like he's looking for them yeah
and you're pushing in on this guy with
the candle
and then the like oh there's a baby and
i'm it's like that's what for me
yeah that's definitely like bumps
but yours too didn't show anything
he could have missed he could have been
aiming at a rat
yeah that was attacking the fan i think
austin made a very good point he was
like shooting a hole in the ground yeah
so that they were stuck in the basement
yeah what's funny because yours is more
or less a
direct like reflection of the glorious
bastard's opening scene yeah no
absolutely i was like i was looking at
that when i was making the cabin like
it's like if people get offended with
you doing that like do you get offended
with quentin tarantino doing it yeah
they're both in services of
entertainment you know he's not making a
dramatic documentary it's literally just
a cool character introduction for hans
ananda yeah it's like
it's still using
world war ii and the holocaust to tell
like you know tell a story and make
entertainment and stuff do you did you
guys so i'm just saying
yeah of course dean and quentin on the
mount rushmore
[Laughter]
did you guys
have like a runner-up idea that you
wanted to do that yeah
you did i wouldn't i just like i would
be canceled for it i think oh no you
think
maybe in canada it'd be canceled oh gosh
is it canadian themed well yeah okay so
someone had mentioned there's the whole
oh god it's so bad
wait wait should we should we say should
we i think we might i think i'm going to
save it i think i'm going to say this
because because i might be in the
offensive concepts you can only deliver
them in bowling animation yeah yeah
right so if i do like artificial maple
syrup or something it's like that's
exactly it
yeah
um okay then if you know if you guys
want to see another bowling video yeah
you'll be able to bring those bring
those to bear yeah yeah
yeah i just love that wren went after
you two yeah it made me laugh because
literally the most shocking parts of his
were just a combination of yours
yeah he must have been thinking oh no
because we had the same joke also like
we both had the same thing which is
halfway through our animations we both
went oh wait that's not what a spare is
spare's not when one is left over
yes
that was fair at all like and i was like
screw it i'm gonna use it anyways and
ren has did the exact same thing
honestly renz was also one of my
favorites because
his was so if it had just been
like the shower heads come down and all
the pins fall down
which it was
that would have been like wren
but because this janky liam neeson comes
running out
kicks the bullet and it makes no sense
because he's also a bowling ball
but that yeah i thought that was and
wacky sound effects and stuff and again
yeah they all survived so that's not a
spare yeah it's totally true i didn't
realize the jankiness
i mean sam said this but the jankiness
actually is most of the comedy like
i've uh one of rents from last time i
think the the jfk one went super viral
and at the end it ends with like this
really janky animation putting its thumb
up and it like broken this broken smile
and stuff
and um i think that's what people sort
of remember about those bowling
animations is the is the janky render
style and yeah
yeah well speaking of yours look very
nice yeah yeah
yeah i it is i wish i could get in the
context i wish i had rolled it back
because i was like i'm learning 3d like
i'm gonna put all my freaking shaders on
and stuff but it would have been much
better served by just being super
janky yeah yeah that's one thing i have
trouble with too is like i do janky but
for some reason i want to pay attention
to the animation too much
which is what i just really like yeah
yeah i think you actually nailed the
aesthetic though because you you're
using
a lot of those as reference like the the
the arm guy the guy yeah the greasy legs
and arms like straight out of those old
animations yeah and i feel like with the
vhs filter and stuff you like you really
but it's like you know when they're when
they're hitting the kid
and they're beating the kid to death
little jiggle yeah his little jiggle
death scene like i spent too much time
like
really hand animating
the motion of these wrenches and bats on
the back to make sure that they
perfectly aligned with the back stuff
that no one would care about if it's
clipping like who cares it's still funny
but yeah i cared about that and i don't
know why so i think if we do it again
i'm gonna really try to dial back yeah i
went the complete opposite i was like
i'm not allowed to adjust anything yeah
so like if it's broken it's in like no
and i thought that was the funniest part
yeah like the guy's just kind of
wandering around and then just slips off
the roof yeah and i was checking the
different like like compilations of old
bowling animations and there's like
there you can see like an evolving like
because the first the earlier ones are
super janky and there's more modern ones
that i'm like oh that actually doesn't
look too bad they have shadows and
reflections and stuff
i was like i'm gonna go full drank on
this
yeah i love the blocky shadows like the
yeah yeah
shadow map yeah that was great how did
you go about doing that was that all in
blender just blender eevee just cranking
everything to lowest it can go down like
i didn't know i could go that low that's
impressive yeah
did you guys have that well i guess
steamed in because he did everything
with nice rendering quality but do you
have a moment of that questions like do
i do shadows or not
yeah yeah yeah uh yeah my debate was on
lighting i got to the point of lighting
and i was like okay maybe i just do a
couple point lights and i rendered like
a still frame of it with no lights and
that's basically what the funnel was i
was like okay no lights no shadows
actually worked pretty well yeah
considering the only reason i
lit it was because
the basement had to be dark right and
there had to be the candle to light the
pins so i was like i can't do it just
like super flat that was the only reason
yeah um because you you were on uh a
little getaway when you did yours right
yeah no we we
uh
were went up to san francisco
but i heard on on the friday i heard
nick mentioned like hey let's do bowling
next week yeah and i knew i'd be gone on
monday when you guys doing the kickoff
and i knew i had i had to edit videos
anyway so i wouldn't have had time so i
like we'd go out hang out all day get
back at night and i would like go to
sleep and i'd be like all right
what do you say if she wakes up and sees
you working on that
i don't know how you guys felt she was a
great barometer of like i'm not pushing
this too far which although you said
your girlfriend last time gave you the
like signed off on it it wasn't a sign
off it was like uh first why
why did you do
when you get insulated with an idea
you your exposure to it it becomes less
offensive the more you're exposed to it
it becomes less and less offensive you
become desensitized to that idea and so
you know in the last iteration i
continued to add i was like okay but
then i got used to that and i continued
to add and continue to add and continue
to add and the one day
you know duration that we were given for
this one was great for that because
i didn't keep looking at it and going
you know it's not as bad as i remember
like let's make it a little worse make
it worse right
100 so when i brought it in i did a work
i worked from home on that and you know
i was completely insulated with this
idea and i brought it in and i think i
showed it to you or griffin first and
the reaction was not what i expected it
was like yeah no i think it was me and i
was like what are you doing
shouting yeah i thought i thought it was
hilarious like in the context it's funny
but yeah it's it's i was completely
desensitized to the idea and so my
girlfriend was the barometer afterwards
i didn't show it to her until after
everything and then she's like ah i get
it
but
you know
maybe not the best call
and i was like
okay okay having seen it now do you
think it was like
more offensive than some of the ones we
did the second round though like no i i
think it would have had the same problem
as ren's first draft but it's just kind
of
violent and you're like
yeah yeah it's just there's not much
payoff on that one yeah there there is
but i don't know that i was great at
crafting the joke of it like because
yeah you know
yeah bowl again right so it's like
you know anyway
it's it's one of those things where yeah
you become so insulated and like immune
to your own offensive thing i'm
realizing i think the my favorite part
of it is
if it's super offensive like you're
saying and the person gets desensitized
is like watching their reaction to
seeing other people be like what are you
doing like that sam shocked me on this
one and he said he's like so layered
like there's so many different reveals
like
it says same afterwards like ah yeah and
we're like sam
you can't do that he's like oh no it's
fine
the way you know he's talking about you
know it's a metaphor and this that and
the other and i was like oh was the the
gota metaphor and he's like he's like oh
yeah
so
i'm not sure sam's ending is going to
make it into the actual oh you may need
to cut that
yeah
but
sam's i was my favorite one
so funny
why did he start it wasn't he the first
one to go yeah oh man was that are you
the first one to go uh
yeah you went first yeah
sam was like
he couldn't he couldn't sit on it any
longer i agree i
don't understand how he was able to
craft such a long like yeah like
particle sims like it's animated really
nicely and he had like the you know the
guy going like this and the plane takes
off was like how did he do this yeah
full rigid body body parts like yeah
it's very impressive yeah i was a big
fan of that one he's been working on it
for years
it's finally relevant and he pulls it
out there you go
yeah it's so fun though i love those
kinds of challenges i will say that you
earn my respect when you crossed the
line the first time we did this you know
someone knowing that you like you had it
in you i was like all right yeah
yeah i want to say i wanted to tease
what's what's deep down
no uh yeah it was again i i didn't do it
on purpose i was just immune to my own
you know thing but uh but yeah no it's
it's nice that that you that you have my
back there i appreciate that yeah yeah
well i mean i'm not sure how much of
your back i had because you still cut it
on the video that's the right call i
regret nothing about it i think it was
the right call everyone made the right
calls except for maybe when i was making
it that was maybe the one wrong call but
here we are i feel like still alive if
we did a third one we'd all nail it that
time because i feel like we kind of have
pushed both sides of like feeling out
the space of it yeah and then i feel
like everybody would knock it out of the
park yeah the third it's funny on this
one i was even on the fence about
killing the kid
talk about getting weak right no
but uh you know the superhero lands i
mean if you haven't seen it yet there's
spoilers all over this thing i think so
go watch it but uh you know i wanted to
do like kind of a twist right so the
idea of not knowing what you got you
gotta bald your first one and then you
think this second ball is coming in to
save your turn
and just get like its brains blown out
from behind it drops to the ground then
they beat the kid to death too it's like
this
devastating thing that has happened
double gutter yeah and i was like maybe
they're all beating the superhero but
he's already had his head blown off and
i was like yeah you got to kill the kid
because you know don't take that out of
that you got to kill the kids yeah
because both your balls failed miserably
so yeah i i liked the idea of that one
but it certainly was less offensive i
think it's the only one where the pins
win they get the other hand it's true
it's true it's very yeah yeah empowering
inspired that's and that's what i wanted
to bring yeah you know yeah
stories from the other side
yeah that's so fun though so
changing topics from something nice and
uplifting here um
i would argue that
well correct me if i'm wrong but the two
of you experienced your first ever viral
video yeah yes yeah that was crazy yeah
adam west batman it was a very cool
moment coming in monday morning yeah
seeing matt reeves had reposted it and
stuff that was nuts to me yeah because
you do forget you're you forget the
reach right yeah it honestly feels like
you're just making stuff with friends
yeah and i constantly forget the people
outside of the office see it it's so
funny i just forget and then yeah stuff
like this happens where the director of
the batman
sees it and likes it and you know we
were talking the other day like adam was
family yeah saw it that was the thing
and we posted it and liked it and like
that's the coolest feeling in the world
you know what i mean that's a direct
impact and
yeah when we were talking about the idea
you know it's it's fun it's a fun
concept certainly but you never expect
it to have legs like that yeah and for
being fenner's first like
video since he came full time i'm like
what a start man it was really good
out the gate
i said all downhill from here yeah
rolling on down the hill now you're
looking for that dopamine
chasing the batman dragon
[ __ ] legit but i feel like in
context of just talking about like
not quite nailing this
you know concept of offensive like you
guys
nailed
putting him in there and having it be
you know we're making fun of it but also
it ends on this note of no this is
actually pretty badass and cool yeah and
and then you know the in loving memory
thing at the end um the fact that his
family saw it and was like this is
respectful of him yeah while still being
super funny and goofy right yeah i
didn't want to feel like we're making
fun of anybody certainly that was not
the intention and matt did an awesome
job with the edit to where it was a
perfect balance of funny and then just
leads into just really badass stuff you
know with the the batmobile and the cop
there when matt showed us the edit once
he got the like to the batmobile sound
bite in there i was like this is cool
like this is awesome yeah it does hit
that here's a note we're like this is
actually really cool and i would really
enjoy a superhero movie like this
i think the trick would be you have to
have your superhero movie be kind of
gritty you have to have it be like real
and grounded you have to have all your
villains be like real villains but then
like batman needs to be aware that he
has plot armor so he doesn't give a [ __ ]
yeah yeah and like that once that once
you flip that switch for batman's just
like i'm gonna do whatever the heck i
want cause i'm batman come on robin
let's go save the day and it's like and
then they like start murdering me like
it gets really intriguing and fun i mean
it's a little bit like the deadpool yeah
i was gonna say little deadpool there
but yeah one man yeah one punch man also
in a way there's an argument that in
that trailer batman is the psychopath
yeah because he's there he's frying this
guy like smoke is coming out of his eyes
he's getting cooked from the inside out
and it cuts around he's just going la la
la la la la because he's like buying
this guy to dance yeah it is a funny
like juxtaposition between the two
although that does i think the new
have you guys all seen the new batman no
no yeah yeah but you can spoil it i
don't care okay well it does come
through like sort of that he is
it's the first batman movie where
bruce wayne is a little unhinged yeah
he's not really sure what he's doing
he's kind of just going out
reliving this trauma of his parents
dying
you know they
there's um i've seen it like three times
now so i'm just like freaking dying but
they go back to the bat cave and you see
bruce wayne here and like he's kind of
like shaking and his eyes turns down the
nirvana yeah he's listening to nirvana
it's um that seemed to me the fact that
he's actually listening to it you're
like oh that's hilarious yeah he's got
the eye pain it's like running down his
face
i liked his like narration of like his
journaling being like he doesn't know
what he's doing and he's like he's like
just out all night straight out of i
don't know if you guys have read the
frank miller comics that he did of
batman year one yeah that's straight out
of batman year one it's like
bruce wayne he's just he's just
wandering around the city being like
and he calls the he calls criminals the
element like
you know and he's like he's in a war
he's like going out every night like
like it's a like he's a soldier and it's
uh i feel like the new movie really
captured that i'm sorry that's like
you're you know you're understanding
like your knowledge well when it comes
to these things blows me away oh dude
this scene in the crew it's like that's
all legit on the spot it just has the
information
i think i said this on another podcast
but i sometimes wish that i when i was a
kid i had put my points into like an
instrument or something else but it was
just like dc comics
and star wars it was like that yeah you
know so but yeah i think
it's funny with the 60s
batman because i mean clearly we're
goofing around in the crew video we know
the original series was a comedy yeah
like it was supposed to be uh goofy
but um
which is funny because i saw a lot of
comments of people saying that uh well
what about george clooney you know
the famous nipple batman yeah
yeah but um i feel like people
also don't get that that movie is a
remake of the adam west series mm-hmm i
didn't get
wow i didn't actually know that until
right now yeah huh i will say of all the
batman movies that came out the second
tim burton batman
nailed the aesthetic for me more than
any other batman has one with danny
devito is penguin yeah yeah yes
like
arguably not as strong of a movie as
some of the other batman movies but like
that vibe is just like
yeah weird like carney kind of almost
like yeah yeah like you feel like the
city was a character it's the in a way
it hits that comic book vibe without
like being a modern comic book movie
right it's like gotham city it's not new
york city it's gotham city i feel i feel
like the new one gets a bit of that back
like gotham has like its own personality
and stuff a little bit but it's
definitely still modern
yeah it's definitely not like because i
feel like the nolan films were
is chicago yeah yeah it's new york city
it was just chicago except for the first
one batman begins there is
i think it's the warrens like that area
where scarecrow releases all the
toxic
fumes and stuff
that feels i know nolan was very
inspired by blade runner and that area
was was all designed it wasn't like a
real area of a city
and that felt very
like this is a unique space but yeah i
feel like the new movie
really
is like gotham is a character in this
film you know it's a place where these
characters it's a world you know
and um it's always raining
yeah always raining like people like
yeah the first scene where he's like
beating up those guys the rain is like
they're all soaked yeah but you know
that kind of yeah it's a little
heightened but um
is it the michael keaton one with the
neck the no neck bat suit that one and
the george clooney one yeah george
clooney also has no neck okay
i watched a smash cut of just uh i think
it was the michael keaton one where it's
just a collection of him turning
it's like two and a half minutes of him
just turning and he just can't do it
without his shoulders and it's so weird
like why did they design it he's coming
like keaton's coming back for the new
flash movie right yeah yeah do you think
he'll be able to move his neck in that
or are they gonna no
the thing is in the movie they
acknowledge it's a rubber bat suit
because remember there's a scene where
he rips off the cowl and it's like he's
just ripping off a rubber cowl and he
has a whole room of costumes so you you
think like does every night when he
takes off his costume does he just rip
it apart
he has a giant room of batman costumes
um
but but yeah it's it's funny because
they tried to solve that problem in dark
knight
because
it is actually a plot point where he is
like i can't move in this suit the suit
from batman begins and lucious makes him
the new suit which is kind of the
classic suit it has like the big bulbous
head yeah i always thought it looked a
little
wacky you know
it looked a little a little like hockey
pads you know keep that line i'm not
wearing hockey pads
but i think there's a really cool
solution with the new one because you
know superheroes silhouette is so
important like the graphic nature of it
and
the new film he has there's no neck
piece that limits his motion but there's
a
uh sort of collar that goes up high
still get the silhouette you get the
silhouette of like
you know the straight down head to the
shoulders
but his his neck is free inside of it
the robert pattinson silhouette's super
similar to the adam west one as well
like in the towel and everything and it
even has a little nose flap like it's
really cool yeah yeah that was also
interesting because a lot of the the
cowls they'll do like it'll be very
gothically designed to look like a demon
and this one it was very
it's almost like he had bought this cowl
somewhere and then put ears on it like
it was just sort of a very simple
thing i do feel like a lot of the batman
films have just really been trying to
capture the magic of the animated series
which nailed batman perfectly yeah you'd
like to find batman for me you can't
nail it harder than that yeah it's just
it's the perfect balance of
the comics
like every version of batman is kind of
in there a little bit because he's
you know he's a superhero he's not he's
not some messed up
psychotic guy which is like the frank
miller version but they still
you know i think there's a famous thing
like the first few seasons they
uh
instead of drawing on white paper or
they drew a background black oh wow and
so basically bringing out the light but
like the idea is that it's always
dark you know awesome wow yeah that's
cool and also like drawing batman so you
can't see his feet so he glides like a
ghost
most of the time you just see his cape
kind of
slide along the ground yeah
yeah
i'd love it if they threw him on a
furniture dolly in the live action
board
actually a bat one wheel would be so
sick like if it was like decked out yeah
yeah i mean that was one thing i loved
about the new movie is that all his
gadgets were like practical like instead
of having the bat wings he just had a
[ __ ] like a squirrel suit yeah he like
eats [ __ ] yeah
no that was great and he yeah he
there's the shot of him getting up to
jump off with the squirrel suit and he
he looks down he's like yeah like him
hesitating
you know because there's a you know the
scene in dark knight where he does the
glider glider for the first time and
christian bale's batman is very stoic
you know he's he knows what he's doing
he's he's like i've committed to this
mission of saving gotham but this this
version of batman is like uh i guess i'm
gonna jump off this building now you
know like yeah it was that whole scene
is so good he's running through the
police station he just looks like he has
no idea what he's doing like where he's
so good yeah matt reeves was talking
about how it's all it's for this
batman's he's just barely getting out of
every situation which is so much more
exciting and his his use of extras there
like especially in the police station
like oh yeah so good like it was almost
like they were an avalanche wherever he
was running whatever door he was going
through it was just
and all these bodies like so many extra
bodies and it made it so intense that
like
every step you take that is now shut
behind you yeah and it's like this this
avalanche that's following you up the
stairs to where you only have one way
out as the avalanche like crescendo is
over the side of the building and he
jumps like that was one of my favorite
scenes from the whole film yeah jan jan
was talking about how the one element
that we've lost in modern batman films
though is the detective part of batman
yeah
he brings you this one has that this one
right you haven't seen it yeah that's
right yeah yeah this one is like a
honestly it feels like a fincher
david fincher like yeah seven or you
know uh zodiac i mean the the riddler's
basically uh serial killer you know and
he leaves notes for batman and so bad
and they're ciphers and like yeah most
of it is him figuring out that he's also
like an influencer
oh yeah yeah he's my favorite scene but
it's the phone he's like what's up guys
yeah it's me the riddler you're like
what is that some w's in the chat like
yeah seriously he's like
like
it's it's very disturbing it's like
truly disturbing because it was i think
the
the most realistic
batman villain in terms of
he's just a nihilistic sort of like
wants to get revenge on everyone yeah
and you know
there's been a lot of stuff with the you
know the january 6th thing and i you
know they probably started making this
movie way before that happened obviously
and
it was just you know there's just
certain threads in there where you're
like oh it's kind of
you know queuing on stuff that's yeah
that's what it was like hitting on was
like him being like this like queueing
on kind of and you're like oh this is
like kind of hitting close to home a
little bit
i know this is a batman movie but this
is kind of dark
yeah no and it yeah it was still pg-13
but it definitely felt
like the by far the darkest
yeah batman and the friggin uh makeup on
the penguin
so good i had no idea who played that
role i thought that was just a guy i did
i didn't think twice i don't know if
you've seen anything
yeah i don't know if you've seen any
images of the makeup i have but it's
recognizable yeah completely i was like
i remember i was sitting there
phenomenal performance as the penguin
and i remember like leaning over my
girlfriend i was like
who is that guy i he's really good yeah
like he has a future in this you know
they had me fooled i love this little
scene where his like ankles are
handcuffed and he does a little penguin
water yeah just like he was like nice
like
much more of those little notes in it
where i felt like the nolan films were
like
it's batman and that's it yeah he's in a
crime movie everything else is real
there's a guy in a bat suit and that's
it but i felt like this movie that was
a lot more respectful of the source
material yeah you know where it was like
it would give you little moments like
that where it's like yeah he's a penguin
or like you know stuff like that which i
thought was cool they uh they just
announced the the sequel officially at
cinemacon just this week like what do
you guys think that's going to be like
guys because i think joker right it's
well joker joker yeah and then i think
mr freeze as well mr freeze would be
really cool i feel like they have you
know going back to the animated series
that's one of the best episodes of the
animated series is um
i'm trying to remember the title don't
miss if he's like trying to save his
wife or whatever yeah any story about
how he lost her they they were it was
the first time the animated scene was
the first time
the mr freeze had been done as like a um
what do you say sympathetic villain
right you know because otherwise he'd
just be he's crazy scientist with a
freeze gun but in the animated series
the idea is that he and they did this in
the schumacher film i think is his wife
has this like rare disease
and so he basically
has her in like cryofreeze and is trying
to save her
and then basically an ax it's like a
spider-man villain it's an accident
happens and then he's like
you know now i basically have to rob
places to
be able to find this cure
get enough money to find this cure and i
feel like they could do
a cool version of it i don't know that
this
that this version of batman
is heightened enough to have like a
freeze gun though right yeah but i
wonder if he just goes like well the
whole the whole thing with like city
being flooded now as well and like i
wonder if they just go hard he's got
like a liquid nitrogen kind of like gun
or something and like
i yeah i don't know because that's
that's also an interesting element is
that i guess spoilers the city's flooded
now
um
and there's there's a lot of story lines
in the comics where
i think this is what they're going to do
in the next film is basically
gotham
i think it's called batman no man land
it's like gotham declares a state of
emergency because of in the comics it's
earthquakes i think now they'll do the
flood but basically
you know nobody can get into the city
and so the villains cut like carve out
little areas of the city as their turf
oh that's cool you know yeah and you
even see it at the end the penguin is
kind of like taking over his spot i feel
like the joker will break out because we
see the joker at the end yeah um
i think
i don't know if you guys heard of the
court of owls there's like a very
a newer storyline that um was written by
this guy scott snyder and artist greg
bulow and
it was the first like new batman story
where they introduced new mythos where
everybody was like oh this is so cool
it's basically like a secret society
that
of gotham elite that they all wear these
like owl masks and basically
it's been a while since i read it but
they basically resurrect they're like
zombie ninjas basically that these
because you know owls hunt bats
and so the idea is that
batman thinks he knows this city inside
out this is his city but there's
actually some deeper darker underbelly
and
that's like in game of thrones with the
golden mask peeps oh yeah you know yeah
the secret society that's cool i like
that
man i love that man yeah
did you guys ever see that one episode
from the animated series where it starts
off with a bat woman dying
i don't know oh girl yeah batgirl falls
off the building yeah she dies and then
the commissioner gordon sends all the
police to like hunt down batman and find
the cave and everything yeah like
nighthawk like it's shot down and yeah
it's dude yeah that
the twist the twist is that it's the mad
hatter i think working with uh scarecrow
yeah
not
tapping into batman making him having a
nightmare but making batgirl have a
nightmare where she realizes that she's
taking these risks with her life but
she's doing it secretly and she could
end up harming her family around her
with them losing her as she does this
dangerous stuff and she's never told
them the truth about what she does and
she has like a heart to heart with her
dad commissioner gordon he's like look
you can do whatever you need to do
you're my daughter i trust you et cetera
and it's like it's a really wholesome
message but it starts off literally with
like main characters dying and you're
like ah
such a good episode for an animated
series and like it's just so cool
watching
because gordon and batman like
especially in the new film it's like you
see how you know tight-knit those guys
are and the whole episode is gordon is
hunting down batman to arrest him and he
knows he's bruce wayne so like there's
no there's no hiding like the bat cave
they kick in the door that's awesome
they're like getting just out on like
the bat boat or something and yeah no
that's like one of my favorite um
episodes and that's what's cool in the
comics and i think they're doing more
in the movies now is
in the in the comics they call them
elseworld stories where they could they
just say here are the characters here's
your you know here's your set of toys
do whatever you want yeah dude to get
joaquin phoenix's joker into new batman
you know yeah wait because they're
technically different like you know
joaquin phoenix his joker yeah and you
know the robert pattinson batman they're
at different times yeah you know but
like say screw it put them in the same
movie yeah they can do that well so they
do they do set up a new a new joker a
new kind of box yourself in there which
i i wasn't 100 on board with i kind of i
was hoping it would be walking phoenix
joker because that would be i felt like
they would have fit in the same universe
those two yeah they would have i guess
like the the whole thomas wayne stuff is
very core to this movie and it's very
different than how they did it in joker
yeah that's true and also the ages would
be different batman like that movie
takes place in like the 70s i think yeah
i hope it just stays its own thing
because that this is kind of what i'm
talking about is it's like a one they
should just kind of yeah they just tell
like here's a joker story and it has
there's no continuity like we're so
you know with marvel yeah it's i think
one of the things the problems with the
marvel movies
is that they're so connected you know
it's like it gives you
what was i what like there was some
marvel movie i went to see recently and
i'm like i realize i'm only sitting here
to see who shows up
like this movie is really in this new
doctor strange movie i'm gonna go in
there and be like all right who's gonna
show up yeah you know and that's like
the whole
that is all your excitement
of it comes like oh there's deadpool you
know like what multiverse can we jump
into yeah exactly yeah well and it's so
crazy too because they're they're the
animated series what if you were like
okay cool finally they're doing
something that's like stan and then it's
like no that's now tying into the actual
like films and stuff yeah
like well they didn't even like what no
that's that's just if now yeah it's just
like if no literally like this the show
the premise was
each episode is a one-shot what if you
know this happened and then they just
they did they do the zombies one and
what if they did yeah yeah no the actual
marvel zombies were like
the avengers are zombies yeah kind of
there's like basically they set it up
there's like a um
from the micro verse which is where
ant-man like you can shrink down there's
this quantum like zombie virus and it
infects everybody and it's a cool
episode yeah but what they do at the end
of the series i guess spoilers for
everybody is
they take characters from each episode
and they're like oh this all exists in
the multiverse and then they bring them
together and then they do something and
now i think in the new doctor strange
movie
the doctor strange from that episode
will be in the new movie yeah and so on
the poster you can see captain britain's
shield and stuff and like oh in on the
poster for multiverse of madness oh wow
so it's like they're gonna bring in
full-on characters like that aren't even
doctor strange and you're like oh what
which
part of me is like
because it's like i watched this thing
uh and i think that's the key to the
marvel thing is for the fans it's like
i've invested in this
and now it gets to pay off where
i guess essentially it's just you get to
be like i saw it first i'd watch a
disney plus and a heartbeat but i
probably won't go to the theater for it
oh for they are playing the avatar two
trailer at the beginning oh no way yeah
the way of water i think is what it's
called yeah when is that coming sounds
like get somebody that looks at you the
way james cameron looks at a glass of
water
it it looks very cool the snippets i've
seen didn't they do like oh
you've seen snippets
i don't know well there was nothing in
my mind
i've seen nothing nothing yeah there you
go he's just saying it looks cool it
looks neat yeah
i'm um
i'm sure we can all safely say it looks
cool yeah yeah
the papyrus font looks great yes yes
what a bold they got to bring it back i
hope so i hope it's like they don't
amped up papyrus like
he is 3d word art papyrus you seen an
snl skit right
how can somebody get away with this yeah
just using papyrus from movie logo
for the biggest movie ever yeah
is um
he's like the whole original cast is is
like saying yeah sam worthington jake
sullivan weaver what has sam worthington
done i don't know
the gods of well yeah clash of clans
or something which actually
that movie's not that bad yeah yeah you
know uh coming back from vegas um
[Music]
nick was like we were listening to a
podcast a darker history podcast and it
was talking about this uh this battle
that happened between like
uh mark antony and like octavius in like
the mediterranean he's like you know no
one ever saw ben hur like the 2016
version just kind of flew into the radar
was like there's this one boat fight
scene that's really good we pulled it up
and it's actually really cool it's you
know they did a lot of ship ramming back
then when they're fighting awesome and
so they have this whole scene but it
stays in under the boat with the slaves
the whole time so it's them just like
being told like real faster you're gonna
die and they really fast and like they
hit something and he's like great and
like he's looking at this little hole in
the side just trying to see what's
happening you see some stuff in the
ships and at one point they get rammed
and just it's always inside the boat
including like once they get rammed and
when it sinks and it's just like so it's
awesome i love when like a director does
a choice like that where you're like
we're not gonna show you like you're
gonna know what's happening it's like
people board the ship but they're on the
deck so you only see like blood and like
oil fall down so good like yeah that's i
feel like that is
what makes
a big vfx film
that's what the only thing that can
bring you into it is like seeing it from
the perspective of the characters i
think john favreau talked about on the
mandalorians he's like
you know we now have the ability to do
anything
it's very important that every shot is
shot with a quote real camera like
is this a helicopter
is this you know if they're out in the
ocean is it another ship that's filming
like you can't
the second i think the pacific the
second pacific rim movie was super
guilty yeah it's just like cameras
moving freely
and now scale doesn't mean anything
you know yeah if you don't have that
restraint it takes away from it like
like
it's like you can do too much of a good
thing you know or you're like we can put
the camera anywhere and you're like yeah
but i don't should you be like yeah
should you yeah so with great power
comes great responsibility yeah
i think the big struggle too with like
being able to do mega vfx now for films
is like
it's really not about your spectacle
it's about your hype like what's the
most hype scene you can make and then
what's the coolest type twist it's like
it's like a good wwe match like yes yeah
cool you can do a big flip but what's
the highest thing that happens the
undertaker just came out as far as like
that [ __ ] [ __ ] going on and that's
again back to marvel it's like that's
what they do really well yeah it's like
captain america gets the hammer that was
like three years ago this week or
something that movie came out that
moment that he got the hammer him
getting the hammer
snippet from uh when james young was
here we talked about that one scene when
they're all like having a little like
sit down they're taking turns trying to
lift the hammer yeah and like captain
america moves it a little bit yeah and
he's like he actually was able to lift
it but he purposely stopped lifting it
to not embarrass thor it's like like
that's such a nice so humble yeah it's
such a good character moment that like
whooshed over my head i thought you just
it was heavy he just moved it a little
bit i didn't realize like oh he just
immediately was able to pick it up and
just stops himself so like he doesn't
embarrass the payoff of that like that
moment in the theater that's one of the
coolest moments i've experienced in the
theater and like everyone just
losing it and the score it's like
it's so hard yeah yeah it's because
and that's
i mean i don't even though i'm
saying like you know marvel thing is
kind of for me like whatever like i
don't
regret that it's the way things are now
with giant hollywood movies because it's
like
you know we've never gotten this like
the amount of time to spend time with
these characters because like comic
books are
soap operas they're like serialized
uh long-form storytelling yeah and
if
you know i was saying like those doing
the dc movies as one-offs but there is
something so satisfying about watching
these characters on this entire
journey like um
and that's that's we've never seen that
in the theaters before so it's just it
takes those you know like a hype moment
and breaking bad where something pays
off after so long yeah you're watching
that by yourself at home like
yeah yeah yeah
but you're in a theater i the the uh in
westwood there's uh
there's the uh
fox theater or i'm trying to remember
the name
we called the bruin theater
and it's 1200 seats and that's what wow
that's where i saw infinity oh come on
now dude that's awesome
it's like a concert like you're just
yeah and that's
that is like the way to experience those
movies their culture it's the only you
think about it it's one of the only
things we have left that is a mass
cultural experience yeah everything else
is so atomized you know yeah getting
into a theater with a bunch of people
screaming and cheering with you is like
that's a unrivaled experience i wouldn't
saw rrr which is bollywood hollywood
wouldn't see that dude it's it's it's
out of theaters i think right now at
least here it might be in some theaters
in the us but when the moment is on the
streaming we're gonna have a party here
come on hurry together let's go yeah i
need to watch it's that good huh it's we
talk about hype moments right i'm just
like because they have their special
effects they have other things but she's
like that's a film that understands like
that anime payoff it's like how to hit
you hard just like attack on titan hits
you it's like how do you hit him so hard
that people start clapping spontaneously
yeah you have to do it in a group
setting too because like i thought about
going solo to see it i thought about
going with a friend you couldn't go and
i'm like
man it's gotta be yeah that so to have
it here would be fantastic well we
watched one time we watched the
bollywood film here saho yeah oh it's so
fun which is yeah it's the same thing
where that one was because you guys
watched that on the yeah and zaha was
like not a good movie no but it's so
like it's so hot it's so hyped still
because it's just the the reveal it's
like you're talking about it's all about
the reveal yeah and it's the same thing
if you lean into it as a viewer
suspension of disbelief
same with wrestling it's the exact same
thing like if you lean into it and you
know scott's back back in my day scott
steiner comes out to challenge booker t
i'm going to
and i remember they had a match and and
we were on team booker t all day and
no one thought he was going to win and
booker t pulled it off and my brother
went for a high five and he slapped my
hand so hard it was it was awful pain
and i looked at him and i remember
totally meaning this i said it was worth
it
it's like that kind of hype for
something that doesn't matter if you
don't care about it like just committing
to caring about it yeah what's the best
part is it the reveal or is it when the
lights go down
and
they start flickering on and off and
you're like where's it gonna be like
that moment where there's no moment
where you're more locked into it the
world just opens up and it's like
anything can happen yeah yeah and you
get excited that's uh bollywood man
so good so so good i personally prefer
it to hollywood i'm just gonna say me
too unfortunately there's like a lot of
jank but when the [ __ ] goes away and a
couple of like it comes together and
it's not distracting
it's so good but man that that one movie
that you reviewed i can't remember what
it was called but where they replaced
the guy made him smaller yeah oh so that
is some of the most impressive work i've
ever seen in my life yeah i don't i
still don't understand how they did it
or why they did it
hire a smaller person
step one
hire a smaller person but like the level
of talent apparently the actor is the
one who paid for the movie and owns the
vfx company oh wow so he was just like i
want to do this and i want to be small i
want to be yeah
he's like in india he's like tom cruise
plus brad pitt yeah in terms of
okay yeah so he's just
in terms of height
[Laughter]
man yeah it's so impressive some of the
stuff so or the fact that you say it's
like legitimately fantastic freddie and
i were just raving about it yesterday
again we got together this is that's
this dance number in the middle called i
think it's a song called not to not to i
guess not to means like homegrown like
the scene starts like they're in this
british palace and there's this whole
like colonialism like a revolution thing
like
and these two indian dudes are there and
one guy's like a country bumpkin like
his buddy is like a cop like a little
more refined but you know they're in the
british palace so like they're just
being looked down upon and like you know
they're doing their waltzes and stuff
like that and this one guy like walks me
like what are you two doing here what do
you guys know about culture can you do
the tango can you do the walls like each
time he busts out an example and like
that guy knows how to dance like oh he's
got some moves
and these guys like yeah like and they
can you do not do not too and they just
bust out this hard
indian dance song but like it doesn't go
into full music video mode it stays
almost like a disney film where it's all
in story right and they're like
challenging this guy but like and then
like the lyrics of the song about how
like
being homegrown and like knowing your
roots like that's where real power comes
from so it's like doing the whole disney
thing with a message
you know they're doing a choreography
and then part way through like towards
the end it shifts and it shifts from it
being like we're choreographed and
singing to like now we're back in
reality we don't know the words of the
song anymore we're still dancing but
we're not choreographed dancing and now
it's like a dance battle to see who can
keep doing this dance move the longest
and who has the energy to like challenge
each other and it's like now the british
versus these two indian guys in a big
circle just doing this move over and
over and like that shift from like song
and like world building to now full on
character like like fighting but in the
the world of this song like i haven't
seen any other indian movies do that
like they're always you know music
videos back to the story yeah whereas
now it's like
okay now we're still now we're back in
the movie song's still going and yeah
it's so good yeah i find the the
like let's cut to just a random music
video to be kind of lazy and i feel
even some american musicals kind of do
that where they don't they don't balance
like
okay what does this song do in this in
the terms of these characters in this
world like is this a dream is this uh
you know is this actually in the world
of the story
and uh yeah you know movie i thought
that really well was rocket man like oh
i haven't seen it it's like i went in
kind of low expectations and i was like
wow like i don't really like musicals at
all and i was like this is really good
like because they do the context of like
it starts to get weird and surreal but
you're like okay it's him being on like
drugs or something yeah and it's done
very well and you're just like the
transitions are like there's this he's
singing like the finale of rocket man
and he shoots off in a rocket and then
next is him waking up like all like
hungover on the plane and like it's the
rocket goes up and hits the plane and
then he's just there and you're like oh
that was awesome yeah it's cool it's
well done like because it's thoughtful
isn't it it's like there's intention
behind it's not yeah it's not an
appendix in the movie yeah it's great
transition moments like and well done
like
it's very cool
yeah i saw i saw
in the heights
which was the lin-manuel
like at the first musical he did and
they did the movie and it was it was
kind of the opposite where the whole
movie is like the sing talking
that they do in like hamilton
so
it for in a film that's really never
worked for me is where the whole movie
is like they're it's like
a song
and
there's no
yeah there's no really delineation
between like when like they're suddenly
they're walking on the side of a
building gravity doesn't work and then
they're still sing talking but it's
normal now
and that
yeah i feel like american films
sometimes have a difficult time with the
with the music well i mean we've kind of
given up on our musical roots yeah a lot
of stuff you know like obviously
musicals are still around here and there
but like
it's not like it was in the 50s or 60s
which is like you just have dance
numbers like every movie like that's how
they get their spectacle yeah yeah
but it's like a whole marketing thing
over in india it's like you need to have
your music video so you can go up on t
series like you need to have
it divided into certain parts and you
have all your regions covered and like
there's all these like different things
they hit for like how their movies get
marketed versus over here
i just love it it feels like that as a
community they've just all decided that
whatever you want to do yeah you can do
it you know how to introduce one of the
characters in that film i mean both
character introductions are amazing but
so there's one they're in a riot right
he's a cop and like they're on a little
outpost surrounded by like a hundred
thousand people and they are like on the
verge of riding they're shaking the
fences they shake the fence so hard and
all the cops like stumble back except
for one and a guy throws like a rock and
like it breaks the picture of like the
chief consulate of like this colony and
it goes like i want that man arrested
and he's like guys like in the middle of
like a million people riding this guy's
like
and he goes into the crowd and he gets
the guy and he brings him back and
that's how they introduce one of the
characters and the movie never goes down
from there it only goes that's awesome
it's so good it's so good
storytelling's just so good like yeah
and it's all fundamentals there's
nothing like super crazy and new it's
just all fundamentals of filmmaking
storytelling just executed well
it's like oh right you can make movies
like this yeah the the stan the standout
example to me is you know the they're
attacking the city
and you're probably intimately familiar
with this one where you know the men
with the shields they pull down the
coconut tree whatever whatever the heck
thing was they launched themselves with
like a cannonball of shields like yeah
that is so high cool man yes
and then like i found myself so many
times watching american films going i
know where this is going okay i know
they're at the low point okay and now
okay we've got about 30 minutes left
you're gonna bring it back up okay oh
resolution fantastic okay let's go home
and this is like at any moment it feels
like anything could happen oh this one's
this one's four hours
okay hmm
and like 20 minutes in which is crazy
yeah this yeah eight twists you know
inside of one twist and like anything
can happen and that to me is the most
exciting part about watching a movie is
being kept on your toes and i feel like
with some some bollywood films you're on
your toes the whole time to where you're
physically exhausted at the end but so
satisfied yeah and it's all so visual
like again with like
i call them like a lot of the movies
that get nominated for oscars are like
actor movies where it's like set put a
camera on a tripod put it in the corner
of the room and then get out of the way
get your coverage
and that's your movie yeah the entire
movie's a winner throw some stock
footage in between scenes right you know
and that's like drone shot dramatic
lighting
and uh yeah like the indian movies they
just nailed the visual storytelling
yeah
so
needless to say we're gonna have an rrr
party i'm so excited for that i'm so
excited june 3rd 2022 baby is that when
it's
out great april may june okay that's not
too bad that's not true it's almost me
oh my gosh dude yeah last time because
we had like a full like indian buffet oh
did you yeah i missed out gosh i'm so
fun dude we'll do it we'll do it next
time just kidding
let's do it and we have more peeps in
the studio now so it can be an even more
epic
let's do a projector on the wall it's
like really like set up
we should sell tickets yeah
it's gonna be a good time everybody we
know is gonna come oh
i wanted it to be the third june 3rd to
be the third already
yeah
that's so cool
yeah
well i guess we're kind of at the end of
our podcast we talked about batman the
whole time but hey what else what else
is new i'm humbled by your knowledge
yeah
well thanks for listening to the podcast
everybody uh i hope you had a good one
um
it's i guess monday right now so
yeah happy monday happy monday it begins
another week begins yeah another chance
to go out there and do your best right
everybody
spin on it i love it go out there and
offend someone let's take back mondays
come on we're taking it back yeah
the second day of the week
all right bye everybody bye